in Pakistan at least eight teachers have
been shot dead at a school the attack
happened during an exam period in kuram
District in the Northwest police are
investigating the motive behind the
killings let's bring in Kamal Haider
who's in Islamabad Forest Kamal what
more are you hearing about the
circumstances of this attack on the
school
well first of all as you mentioned the
incident took place in kurum District
this is very close to the Avalon border
this is also an area which has seen in
the past uh sectarian violence between
Shia and Sunni tribes in the area this
particular attack are targeted
the teachers while they were in the
staff room seven of them and they were
there basically to conduct examinations
which are underway throughout the
province for lower Secondary School
exams which are being held so are still
mysterious circumstances because not
many people were able to see what
transpired there how many attackers were
involved what won the motive the
likelihood that the good spot more
sectarian violence in this region which
has seen violence between sectarian
groups in the past as well and also that
another teacher and that would be the
eighth teacher was gunned down and not
far away from that location as he was
traveling in a vehicle so indeed a
gruesome incident most of the teachers
that were killed belonged to the Turi
tribe this is a Shia tribe in that area
Kamal thank you for the update Kamal
Haider in Islam about there and in
Pakistan's North waziristan District Six
security forces and three gunmen have
been killed in fighting